er war jung gutaussehend und er setzte
sich gern in szene
gut möglich dass egon schiele heute
selbst von sich in alle welt verschicken
würde rund 170 selbstporträt smarte egon
schiele
einen teil davon zeigt kurator oliver
weg in eine ausstellung im kunsthaus
zürich
hat das rx und selbstbewusst sie braucht
wahrscheinlich um überhaupt an dem könne
bestehe ich bin meine kunst ist wichtig
ist hat er erwarte bis sage das gelang
egon schiele seine gequält wirkenden
gesichter sie prägten sich ein
die schaffenskraft des gustav klimt
schülers an denen die figur im
hintergrund auf diesem bild erinnert war
ungebremst seine figuren haben eine
irritierende eindringlichkeit
die ausstellung zeigt auch die üppigen
körper bilder einer modernen expressive
der malerin janice evtl
die britin arbeitet immer mit modellen
doch sie malt den fremden körper ihr
eigenes gesicht und steigert so die
intensität
auch chile sucht intensität
er inszeniert sich in verschiedenen
posen schön
hoch mäßig
grimassierend
sein hauptwerk entsteht zwischen 1908
und 1918 die bäume setzt sich gerade mit
nietzsches schriften auseinander
freuds psychoanalyse steckt noch in den
kinderschuhen doch dass ich beruhigt in
den fokus in einem brief schreibt chile
wenn ich mich ganz sehe werde ich mich
selbst sehen müssen selbst auch wissen
was ich mir
seine studien sind eine suche nach sich
selbst
doch sie sind noch mehr unbedingt
abbilden sondern sehr viel mehr um genau
der körperliche befindlichkeit gezwungen
wo denn eigentlich allgemein gültig wird
also das könnte eigentlich jede körper
sie breiteten fall einfach ganz
persönlich individuell egon schiele
stellte seinen körper also für die kunst
zur verfügung
vielleicht hätte er damit irgendwann
aufgehört doch 1918 stirbt er
überraschend an der spanischen grippe
einige seiner selbstbildnisse wirken als
hätte er seinen frühen tod geahnt